>> CLERON: Hi, my name is Mike Cleron. I’m
the engineer on the Android Development Team.
Android is an open software platform for mobile
development. It is intended to be a complete
stack that includes everything from the operating
system through middleware, and up through
the applications. Now I'm going to focus in
detail on a few of the APIs that I think provide
fertile ground for innovation. The first is
the location manager. This is a set of APIs
that allows you to get geographic information.
It will let you find out your current location,
and it will also let you register to receive
notifications if you get close to something
interesting. So you can actually register,
you can register an intent with the location
manager that will be fired when you get close
to a point that you specify. And that lets
you do things like being notified when you
get close to one of your friends, or it lets
you be notified when you get close to, say,
an ice-cream shop that has particularly good
ice-cream in it. It has that kind of an interesting
innovative application with this kind of API
enables. The location manager will use GPS
if the device comes equipped with GPS. If
it doesn’t, it will make do with whatever
information is available that might be getting
information from cell tower IDs or if there's
a Wi-Fi network that has geographic location
information in it, we'll use that information
to try to at least narrow down where you are.
While building applications for the Android
platform, we found that it was useful to have
and always on data connection so that the
server could send notifications to devices
running the Android platform. It turned out
that it’s such a useful piece of infrastructure
that we decided to package it up and make
it available as part of the public framework.
And that has been done by creating the XMPP
Service APIs. The XMPP Service allows any
application to send device-to-device data
messages to any user who's running Android
upon their device. Now that data can be whatever
information make sense with the application.
So for a multiplayer game, that might be that
I’ve moved my knights to a particular location,
or whatever make sense for the game. But it
could also be something else like geographic
information. So with appropriate permissions
and security, the user could send their location
to their buddies so that their buddies could
actually see where they are at any given time
and plot that information on a map. Again,
this works with any Gmail account, so any
application can send this type of peer-to-peer
messages without having to build any server
infrastructure. The next API is one of my
favorites. It’s called the Notification
Manager, and it allows any application to
put a notification into the status bar. We
use the status bar for things like SMS notifications,
voicemail notifications, all of the typical
things you’d expect to see on a phone. However,
we make that same facility available to any
application. And so, that means the developers
can have the same power to alert the user
to interesting events as what have traditionally
been built-in applications. This has a lot
of benefits. First, it means that all notifications
have a consistent presentation. Now the way
we do it in the UI, we have a visible preview
of what the notification means. So if an icon
appears in the status bar, you can click on
it or touch it to make it active so you can
see a preview of what it means, which means
you don’t have to figure out what each of
30 different hieroglyphics means. Then, if
you want to act on that notification, you
can simply touch on it and you will be taken
to whatever application is responsible for
that notification. This allows a lot of really
interesting scenarios. It means that applications
can notify you of things like when an auction
is ending, or if someone has invited you to
be their friend on a social network, or if
a bus is coming. And all of those notifications
can have the same level of prominence in the
UI as something like voicemail or the other
built-in notifications. And finally, I’d
like take a minute to talk about the view
system in Android. Android provides a really
rich toolkit of built-in views, and you can
use those to assemble your applications out
of standard parts. So we provide things like
playlist view and a grid view, a gallery view.
We provide all the standard widgets like buttons
and check boxes. And by combining those things,
you can build your applications really quickly.
We've also done a lot of work in the framework
to support multiple input methods and multiple
screen sizes and multiple keyboard configurations
in the view system itself so that you don’t
have to worry about that in your application.
So for example are list of views work with
touch but they also work if you want to drive
them with a [INDISTINCT] D-pad. And that’s
just a built-in facility of the view framework.
In addition to that sort of views, we also
are introducing two really innovative views.
The first is a map view. This is an actual,
this is an implementation of the same map
rendering engine that’s in our maps application.
But we decided to make that available as a
view so that applications can have really
tight integration with geographic data. So
it’s, of course possible to always launch
the map application to display a particular
location. But what the maps view let you do
is actually embed a map view in your application
so that you can control it from your own code
so you can set it to a particular locations,
zoom in, zoom out, pan the map, control all
of that from your own code to build whatever
kind of application you want to build based
on that. We've done something similar with
the browser. There’s a browser application
that you can launch to display a webpage,
but we also have a web view that enables you
to embed HTML content as a view in your application
that you can then fill with whatever data
make sense for your app. Personally, what
I’m hoping to see come out of the Android
effort is the kind of innovation that comes
from what I call a mash up effect. We really
had two goals in mind when we set out to create
Android. The first was to provide developers
with a powerful toolkit for building new types
of experiences. This toolkit includes things
like the application framework, the view system,
things like the maps view and the web view
that you can embed in your application, device-to
device messaging through XMPP, location services,
notifications, and all the other pieces of
our API. But the second and more important
goal was to be sufficiently open and extensible
to allow these pieces to be combined in ways
that we really haven’t imagined yet. If
you're interested in finding out more about
Android, I encourage you to visit the developer
site and download the SDK. In the SDK, you
will find a lot more documentation and sample
code, and you’ll also be able to try built-in
applications of your own. There's also a developer
group that you can join to find out more information.
And I also encourage you to check back frequently
because we’ll be posting updates to the
SDK as the platform of your choice. Thank
you for watching.